ja man kann nicht nur von zigaretten
medikamenten alkohol und so weiter
süchtig werden oft ist auch von sexsucht
ordnungs sucht internetsucht unter
kaufsucht die rede aber sind das
überhaupt süchte oder kann exzessives
verhalten auch gar keine sucht sein wird
also der begriff sucht ja viel zu
inflationär gebraucht kann also sex so
zum beispiel ganz normal sein
das klären wir jetzt mal klicks um
science and future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen clixoom zahlen sie
im future gibt es jetzt übrigens auch
als podcast sie links zu apple podcast
und spotify sind unten in der video
beschreibung täglich vier tassen kaffee
pro tag und zwei episoden der neuen
serie jeden monat mindestens ein neues
t-shirt shoppen und jeden samstag in den
club zum feiern und trinken sind wir
also alle süchtig klar ist der begriff
sucht ist negativ belegt kein wunder
denn nicht nur harte drogen schaden
unserer gesundheit gewaltig schätzungen
zufolge gibt es in deutschland bis zu
1,8 millionen medikamentensüchtige zwei
millionen alkoholabhängige und achtung
20 millionen menschen die rauchen und
abhängig von nikotin sind und nur weil
zigaretten und alkohol frei auf dem
markt verfügbar sind heißt das noch
lange nicht dass wir unserem körper
damit etwas gutes tun
die weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
2018 einen bericht veröffentlicht werden
die fatalen folgen des alkoholkonsums
auf den punkt bringt drei millionen
menschen sterben weltweit dadurch und
das pro jahr
und das sind mehr opfer als durch gewalt
verkehrsunfälle und aids zusammen
das ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
harte drogen wie etwa kokain zerstören
den menschlichen körper innerhalb von
kürzester zeit kokain beispielsweise
schädigt das gehirn indem es die
gehirnzellen dazu bringt sich selbst zu
verdauen
ein us forschungsteam aus baltimore hat
2016 in einem tierversuch gezeigt dass
die nervenzellen unter einfluss von
kokain ihre zelleigene müllabfuhr so
krass hochfahren das dadurch eben auch
zellbestandteile entsorgt werden die
eigentlich lebenswichtig sind aber auch
beim menschen macht diese droge nicht
nur süchtig sie verändert und tedi
das gehirn auch langfristig die
konsumenten von kokain haben nicht nur
ein fünffach erhöhtes risiko für
schlaganfälle ihr gehirn altert auch
vorzeitig trotz aller risiken drogen zu
konsumieren gehört in der sogenannten
leistungsgesellschaft längst zur
normalität eine erschreckende erkenntnis
und so heißt es im drogen- und
suchtbericht der bundesregierung von
2018 sucht ist kein randphänomen der
gesellschaft sondern betrifft viele
menschen abhängigkeitserkrankungen sind
schwere chronische krankheiten die zu
erheblichen gesundheitlichen
beeinträchtigungen und vorzeitiger
sterblichkeit führen können der sucht
liegt meist ein komplexes geflecht aus
individuellen vorbelastungen bestimmten
lebensumständen erfahrungen im umgang
mit anderen menschen störungen in
emotionalen gleichgewicht dem einfluss
wichtiger bezugspersonen und der
verfügbarkeit von suchtstoffen zugrunde
doch klar ist eben auch nicht nur drogen
können süchtig machen sondern auch sport
sex das internet oder aber das
smartphone wenn man den begriff sucht in
einem satz definieren will kommt man
dazu es handelt sich um eine
abhängigkeit von einem bestimmten stoff
oder von bestimmten verhaltensweisen
forschende haben herausgefunden dass
beispielsweise beim joggen und beim
abhängen am smartphone ähnliche prozesse
im menschlichen körper ablaufen wie bei
einer echten sucht der körper sorgt
dafür
denn nicht nur drogen aktivieren
rezeptoren im gehirn dazu die
suchtexperte martina pötschke langer
es ist ja nicht so dass unser körper die
rezeptoren extra dafür hat dass wir
drogen nehmen können die dort andocken
wenn wir gutes essen zu uns nehmen oder
guten sex haben dann tut das unserem
körper gut er sorgt für vitalität und im
idealfall sogar für nachkommen
glücklicherweise kommt das glückshormon
dopamin nämlich von natur aus in unserem
gehirn vor und das wird freigesetzt bei
schönen dingen etwa beim sport beim
gaming beim shopping beim sex oder bei
einem leckeren essen beim nächsten mal
wird das glückshormon dann aber bereits
vor diesem ereignis also vor dem sex mit
demselben partner oder vor demselben
essen und so weiter frei so bringt unser
körper und dazu dieses ereignis dringend
zu wiederholen und genau das ist einer
der zentralen prozesse die der sucht
im gehirn zugrunde liegen und an sich
ist das ja auch nicht verkehrt denn der
körper motiviert uns durch dieses system
und zwar immer wieder das zu tun was uns
gut tut doch dieser effekt kann
natürlich eben auch ausufern beim
rauchen beispielsweise wirken somit
nicht nur die inhaltsstoffe des tabaks
auf unser belohnungssystem ein sondern
auch das körpereigene dopamin wird
freigesetzt viele raucherinnen und
raucher empfinden den zug an der
zigarette als pause oder als wohlfühl
moment den man sich verdient hat erst
vor einigen jahren hatte ein spanisches
forschungsteam herausgefunden dass das
belohnungszentrum bei übergewichtigen
menschen stärker auf essens reize
reagiert als bei normalgewichtigen
die fachleute schließen daraus dass das
essen bei menschen mit übergewicht
durchaus suchtgifte züge aufweist in
ihrer studie durften die teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer sich nach herzenslust an
einem riesigen buffet bedient später
bekamen sie fotos von dem essen gezeigt
und gleichzeitig wurde mit hilfe der
funktionellen magnetresonanztomographie
fmrt ihre hirnaktivität aufgezeichnet
spannend für die fachleute war dabei vor
allem eine frage welche hirnareale sind
funktionell miteinander verbunden das
ergebnis ist super spannend denn die
verbindung zwischen einen bestimmten
bereich der hirnrinde und einem
kerngebiet des centers war dabei
besonders aktiv genauso wie bei
süchtigen die ihr suchtmittel sehen kein
wunder also dass es übergewichtigen so
schwer fällt weniger zu essen dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam unsere
studie stützt die idee dass die
belohnungs reaktion auf essens reize bei
übergewichtigen mit neuronalen
veränderungen verbunden ist die dänen
bei der drogensucht ende möglicherweise
könnte diese erkenntnisse bald genutzt
werden um übergewichtigen zu helfen
gezielt dagegen den essens tank
vorzugehen
ähnliche glücksgefühle kennt man aber
auch aus anderen bereichen des alltags
nämlich dass man sich nach dem sport so
richtig gut fühlt oder aber nach dem
shopping total glücklich ist über die
neuen klamotten viele brauchen auch erst
mal eine tasse kaffee um richtig in den
tag zu starten heißt also sucht geht
auch ohne drogen ohne substanzen die man
schluckt spritzt oder einatmet etwas
immer wieder zu tun weil es für kurze
zeit glücklich macht und freude bereitet
reicht schon aus wobei beim café spielt
natürlich auch das koffein eine gewisse
rolle aber das ist viel schwächer als
bei harten drogen
und so kommt es dass die grenze zwischen
einer harmlosen angewohnheit und einer
schädlichen sucht verschwimmt die
fachstelle für suchtprävention des
österreichischen bundeslandes steiermark
vivid schreibt dazu auf der webseite
um zu vermeiden dass der suchbegriff
beliebig verwendet wird ist es
allerdings notwendig auch in
zusammenhang mit nicht substanz
gebundenen sicht und klare grenzen zu
ziehen und darauf zu bestehen dass sucht
krankheits charakter hat und nicht mit
gewohnheit oder der natürlichen
abhängigkeit von nahrung kleidung
gleichzusetzen ist von sucht sollte man
nur sprechen wenn das zugrunde liegende
problem verhalten zu einem eigendynamik
zwanghaften verhalten wird aha
interessant im internationalen
krankheits verzeichnis psychischer
störungen dem sogenannten dsm diagnostic
and statistical manual of mental
disorders ist die glücksspielsucht
eingetragen und zwar als einzige sucht
die durch ein verhalten ausgelöst wird
im klartext heißt das also im dsm wird
die glücksspielsucht in dieselbe
kategorie eingestuft wie drogensüchtige
hier in deutschland sind etwa eine halbe
million betroffenen anhand der
glücksspielsucht lässt sich ein
typisches merkmal der sucht beschreiben
die sogenannte toleranzentwicklung um
dasselbe glücksempfinden auszulösen
braucht es immer höhere einsätze ein
katalog listet bei der glücksspielsucht
insgesamt neun typische merkmale auf
wenn viel davon erfüllt den sprechen
fachleute von einer sucht so lässt sich
analysieren wie tief man in der sucht
spirale steckt dieser katalog ist auf
andere suchterkrankungen übertragbar
typisch für eine krankhafte sucht ist
auch dass sie eine art
ersatzbefriedigung ist für das was einem
sonst fehlt zum beispiel die liebe eines
anderen menschen die wertschätzung der
kolleginnen und kollegen oder eine
arbeit die einen erfüllt durch
suchtverhalten kann man vor diesen
problemen fliegen der belohnungs effekt
im körper funktioniert zuverlässig auch
wenn er dann fehlgeleitet ist doch wie
schlimm ist es wirklich 7 serien
episoden am stück zu gucken wie ich es
mir passiert es jetzt wären corona jeden
tag mehrere tassen kaffee zu trinken
mache ich auch oder aber täglich sex
haben zu wollen naja werden möchte das
nicht ja ist das alles normal oder
handelt es sich um harmlose an
einheiten oder haben wir es dann mit
einer gefährlichen sucht zu tun
in der wissenschafts community gibt es
zum thema sex und verschiedene ansätze
manche bedienen sich hier an ähnlichen
kriterien wie bei den substanz
gebundenen süchten oder anderen
verhaltenspflichten andere fachleute
betonen dass sexuelles verhalten sehr
viel komplexer ist und es deswegen viel
zu einfach sei sex sucht mit klassischen
süchten zu vergleichen die frage an
dieser stelle
wann ist viel zu viel wie oft darf man
am tag masturbieren wie oft pornos
schauen und wie oft sex haben
entscheidend hierbei ist ob die
betroffene person selbst leidet und auch
ob lebensbereiche dadurch leiden ist der
arbeitsplatz gefährdet oder aber die
partnerschaft die sexualtherapeutin
angelika ex schreibt dazu auf zeit.de
in meiner klinischen arbeit gehe ich mit
diagnostischen lebens generell
vorsichtig um
ich nehme allerdings die person und ihr
leiden sehr ernst und erkundige mich wie
sie und ihre angehörigen das verhalten
beschreiben und bewerten entscheidend
ist das ausmaß an kontrolle dass er oder
sie über das eigene sexuelle verhalten
erlebt welche funktionen es hat wer am
meisten darunter leidet welche
emotionalen bedürfnisse sexuell
aufgeladen werden wenn es sinn ergibt
schauen wir dann parallel wie das
verhalten losgelassen werden kann und
wie die person mit ihrem zuständen
anders als bisher umgehen kann
dazu passt ganz gut die feststellung der
sexualforscher alfred kinsey der es als
äußerst schwierig beschrieb ein
normalmaß sexuellen begehrens zu
definieren zitat nymphomanin ist jemand
der mehr sex will als man selbst doch
was sexuell als normal gilt ist auch
stark von kulturellen einflüssen
abhängig wenn aber symptome wie
exzessive masturbation oder die
abhängigkeit von cybersex oder
telefonsex über mindestens sechs monate
bestehen und zu einem großen
leidensdruck führen ist in der
fachsprache von hypersexualität die rede
schätzungen zufolge wird diese von etwa
fünf prozent der bevölkerung im laufe
des lebens entwickelt anders herum wer
20 mal am tag masturbiert und damit zum
einen glücklich ist und auch damit
zurecht kommt er ist eben nicht süchtig
wenn man aber selbst feststellt dass
sich eigene vorlieben wie etwa shopping
oder das abhängen mit dem smartphone
tief auf den alltag auswirken sollte man
sich hilfe holen beispielsweise wenn man
freunde und familie anlügt um solche
vorlieben zu verbergen wobei das
sexleben
das darf man schon verheimlichen aber
wenn man auf diesem wege vor problemen
flieht und zwischenmenschliche beziehung
und arbeit und karrieremöglichkeiten in
gefahr bringt und nicht immer ist eine
stationäre behandlung der letzte ausweg
dazu die psychologin chantal mörsen
sucht ist keine einbahnstraße viele
schaffen es ohne professionelle hilfe
sich dem suchtverhalten lang genug zu
entziehen weil der sex sucht ist es
beispielsweise nicht das ziel an der
behandlung abstinenz zu werden eine
sache ist aber klar erst ohne eine sucht
hat man die kraft sein leben zu ändern
erst dann hat man den kopf frei um
herauszufinden was ein wirklich
glücklich macht denn das glücksgefühl
durch die sucht das ist ja nur
vorgegaukelt es ist kein echtes
glücksspielsüchtige jugendliche rasten
aus fortnight und co machen psychotricks
abhängig anklicken anschauen und klicks
zum science and future diesen kanal
abonnieren und übrigens die bundesweite
sucht und drogen hotline ist 24 stunden
unter 01805 31 30 31 erreichbar die
nummer ist auch unten in der video
beschreibung also bis dann bleibt dran